[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal préparé par les
équipes de tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 22
novembre voici les titres de cette
édition
le secours catholique a dévoilé son
rapport annuel sur la pauvreté en france
un focus sur l'aide alimentaire selon
l'anc est très 2 7 millions de personnes
y auraient eu recours en 2020 les
détails du rapport dans ce journal une
dictée pour tous a pris place à la
verrière ce week end un événement
gratuit et ouvert à tous pour lutter
contre l'illettrisme mais aussi s'amuser
à déjouer les pièces de la langue
française c'est le comédien yvelinois
steve tran qui s'est prêté au jeu de la
lecture pour l'occasion et puis du côté
football c'est un début de saison marqué
par l'agressivité des supporters dernier
incident en date un projectile reçu par
dimitri payet dimanche lors du match
lyon marseille le point sur les
violences au sein du stade dans cette
édition
le maire de saint germain en laye et
arnaud péricard a lancé le 18 octobre
dernier un comité de soutien au
président de la république une première
rencontre s'est tenue ce vendredi à 19
novembre sur le thème de l'éducation le
prince is le principe capter est les
propositions des citoyens pour commencer
la construction du futur programme d'
emmanuel macron le reportage de nicolas
landry après tout innové en main en
pédagogie c'est sous les rythmes
scolaires comment innover dans les
politiques publiques de l'éducation
l'une des questions posées durant cette
première soirée du comité de soutien de
saint germain en laye à l'action du
président de la république une
cinquantaine de personnes ont participé
à cet atelier autour de l'éducation
j'aime bien le format c'est très très
intéressant de faire travailler les gens
ensemble et puis faire émerger des idées
je trouve ça très intéressant pouvoir
échanger avec des gens crient qui semble
passionner par l'éducation en plus on a
à la fois des parents des professeurs
des gens intéressés par le sujet des
fils d'enseignante voilà c'était a
vraiment un panel très varié ces comités
de soutien à l'action du président de la
république une initiative nationale mise
en place à saint germain en laye par le
maire arnaud péricard pour porter la
potentielle future candidature d'
emmanuel macron je pense nos citoyens
ont des choses à dire ils ne sont
peut-être plus membre d'un parti ou
d'une association politique mais ils ont
des choses à dire et donc l'objectif
notamment de cette réunion c'est de
capter voilà de capter cette
intelligence collective de capter ces
idées pendant 30 minutes les
participants ont échangé sur quatre
thématiques avant cela un rappel a été
fait sur les mesures mises en place
durant le quinquennat avec notamment le
dédoublement des classes de cp et ce1 en
zone d'éducation prioritaire je crois
que c'est emblématique et puis moi pour
avoir visité pas mal de classes de
petites phrases comme ça on voit qu'à
douze élèves il ya vraiment un niveau de
calme et que les élèves travaillent par
petits groupes d'une façon complètement
différente et dans de bien meilleures
conditions objectifs de ces ateliers
nourrir le futur programme du président
sortant prochaine thématique traitée à
saint-germain-en-laye l'économie le 15
décembre 2021
et autres comités de soutien emmanuel
macron celui de villepreux l'on sait le
22 septembre dernier une initiative de
l'actuel maire jean baptiste à monique
en vue des élections présidentielles
donc à venir une première soirée des
changes est organisée ce lundi soir 22
novembre à 20h30 inscription via le mail
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
le thème de la soirée relance économique
et pouvoir d'achat un événement présence
de jean-noël barrot député de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines
[Musique]
en 2020 en france entre 5 et 7 millions
de personnes ont eu recours au centre de
distribution alimentaire c'est ce qui
ressort d'une étude réalisée par le
secours carole catholique caritas sur
l'état de la pauvreté en france en 2020
pour en parler avec nous nicolas d'andry
bonsoir bonsoir ghislaine vous êtes
journaliste pour tv 78 qu'elles sont
déjà les principaux enseignements de
cette nouvelle étude eh bien d'abord
justin un chiffre à retenir 1 537 euros
le niveau de vie médian des personnes
reçues en 2020 par le secours catholique
trois profils de ménage sont accueillis
par l'association aux 25% de mères
isolées 23 % d'hommes seuls et 22% de
couples avec enfants
plus de la majorité des personnes
accueillies à moins de 45 ans enfin
justine 22 % sont sans ressources
financières
et qu'en est-il de l'aide alimentaire
est bien la demande et en os 54% des
personnes reçues par le secours
catholique ont bénéficié d'une aide
alimentaire en 2020 sur les ménages qui
ont reçu un chèque alimentaire de
l'association 80% sont concernés par une
insécurité alimentaire modérée ou grave
cette situation concerne des personnes à
faibles revenus mais des ménages et des
ménages pardon ayant des ressources
issues du travail sont aussi touchés la
raison et c'est un budget plus serré
face à des charges qui sont de plus en
plus importante et qu'en est il donc
dans le département nicolas dans les
yvelines le secours catholique a
accueilli 27 mille personnes en 2020
parmi eux 32 % ont demandé une aide
alimentaire même facteur explicatif le
manque de ressources financières
si 40% 44 % des ménages concernés n'ont
aucune ressource financière 22 % ont une
activité rémunérée toujours le même
problème un budget toujours plus serrés
face à des sharks plus en plus
importante et s'il faut retenir une
chose justin de la situation en libye
menace c'est que 27% des personnes en
précarité alimentaire ne s'alimente pas
régulièrement merci beaucoup pour les
informations nicolas d'ambri je le
rappelle cette journaliste pour tv 78
[Musique]
je vous en parlais tout à l'heure en
titre le football en début de saison est
marquée par les violences au sein des
stades avec récemment notamment ce
dimanche un projectile reçu par dimitri
payet au début du match lyon marseille
par conséquent interrompue jean-pierre
meurillon bonsoir vous êtes avec nous
bonjour merci vous êtes le président
vous du district de football des
yvelines ont fait le point avec vous
donc sur le sujet sur les violences au
sein des stades vous qui êtes
directement concernés par le sujet
comment vous avez réagi face au violent
justement de dimanche écoutez c'est
consternant et encore le mot est faible
c'est totalement concernant le un match
de foot ça doit être la fête pour les
spectateurs et coquelles que quand elle
quelques individus viennent là dans un
exutoire pour pouvoir faire ce qu'ils
ont fait hier c'est je répète c'est
ahurissant encore dans les yvelines est
ce qu on est concerné par ce genre de
comportement alors non parce que les
vins nom d'une certaine façon oui dans
le foot amateur mais pas de cette façon
là habituellement ce qui est ce qui est
mis en avant c'est le sait le la
violence qui peut intervenir
éventuellement
chez les joueurs là on n'est pas chez
les joueurs là on est dans les
spectateurs est-ce que selon vous il ya
une évolution qu'il soit positif ou
négatif justement de la violence de
l'agressivité des supporters mais à côté
c'est un constat c'est la neuvième fois
cette saison en ligue 1 il y à des
incidents avec les supporters c'est la
neuvième fois ça a commencé le 8 août le
22 août le 18 septembre le 22 septembre
le 22 octobre le 24 octobre
le 21 novembre ça continue j'ai vu que
madame la ministre des sports a dit
qu'il fallait prendre des dispositions
j'espère que des dispositions vont être
prises pour lutter contre ça parce que
ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça
justement comment on pourrait prévenir
ce genre de situation est ce qu'il ya
des débriefings au niveau de l'arbitrage
peut-être ou ou des consignes notamment
pour arrêter un match si besoin alors
les les instructions sont données
effectivement aux arbitres pour que
faire en sorte que le les matches soit
arrêtée lorsqu'il y a un risque
d'insécurité soit pour les joueurs soi
même pour les spectateurs c'est comme ça
que les choses se passent alors ça peut
commencer d'un par une interruption
momentanée qui dure quelques minutes et
puis lorsqu'il y a effectivement ensuite
s'il ya plusieurs interruptions épais
que larbi t'arrives pas à maîtriser les
choses effectivement ils se concertent
avec les délégués qui sont désignés par
la ligue de football professionnel est
il ce concerne avec les autorités
publiques et ensuite il prend une
décision c'est ce qui s'est passé hier
est justement pour venir ailleurs vous
avez dit il ya eu neuf incidents déjà en
ligue 1 il nous semble quelles sont les
sanctions actuelles est ce qu'elles sont
suffisantes finalement écouté je les
connais pas dans le détail parce que je
les vois comme vous dans la presse mais
manifestement elles sont insuffisantes
puisque ça continue si elles étaient
suffisantes ça s'arrêterait
je pense aussi qu'il faut il faudrait
sans doute que les lits et en face de
ces agissements des réponses pénales qui
soit adaptée
et ajustements je le vois avec vous
aujourd'hui il ya une grande proximité
avec les joueurs notamment des
supporters qui descendent parfois sur le
terrain après match pour voir des
joueurs parce que ça pourrait être une
cause aussi cette proximité ce qu'il
faudrait finalement arrêté cette
proximité avec les joueurs mais
normalement la proximité que les joueurs
ne doit pas le temps pas se faire
pendant le match il est interdit à un
spectateur d'entrer sur le terrain tout
simplement on n'a pas le droit d'entrer
sur un terrain et c'est d'ailleurs
sanctionné pénalement mais ensuite
est-ce que les sanctions pénales sont
suffisantes est ce qu'elles sont
appliquées c'est aussi toute la question
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'on
est un peu impuissant aujourd'hui face
aux supporters justement mais j'espère
qu'on n'est pas un puissant parce que si
on est impuissant face à face aux
supporters ça va continuer
et
et j'ai vu que la mise et sport
aujourd'hui a dit il faut impérativement
que des dispositions soient prises pour
que ça s'arrête elle dit que le football
risquent de ne plus être apprécié comme
il l'est actuellement justement c'est ce
que j'allais vous demandez continue on
est dans des conditions comme ça est ce
que c'est faisable ou finalement ce
qu'il faudrait pas par exemple arrêter
la compétition un temps ou alors c'est
très compliqué parce que est ce qu'il
est ce qu'il est nécessaire d'arrêter la
compétition parce que quelques individus
se comporte mal est-ce qu'il faut pas
avoir une autre action je vais pas vous
donner la réponse je les ai pas aussi si
on avait les réponses il ya longtemps
qu'elle serait mise en oeuvre dès
maintenant du moins ce qui me gêne et en
moins c'est que il y a dans le sport du
mimétisme c'est à dire celui qui regarde
le match de foot qui est joué en ligue 1
ou en ligue 2 et qui voit des uns des
comportements comme cela il peut
certains qui sont un peu faibles je
dirais
risque de penser qu'on a le droit de le
faire dans le sport amateur
merci beaucoup jean pierre marion
d'avoir été avec nous je le rappelle
vous êtes le président du district de
football des yvelines merci beaucoup
[Musique]
lancée en 2013 par abdellah boudour la
dictée pour tous est un événement qui
rassemble petits et grands le but
favoriser l'accès à la lecture et à
l'écriture dans une ambiance conviviale
et sans jugement et déjà 421 indique t
on pu être réalisées partout en france
et même à l'international samedi dernier
c'est un la verrière qu'elle se
déroulait en présence du comédien steve
tran grégory de canale et céline charles
était sur place
organisé par l'association force des
mixités la dictée pour tous invité
samedi dernier parents et enfants à
venir s'adonner à l'exercice difficile
de la dictée un moyen de lutter contre
l'illettrisme et l'inégalité des chances
en réunissant les gens autour du
patrimoine linguistique français c'est
la première fois que je fais ça depuis
que j'ai quitté l'école en 1975 et puis
way pour voir mon niveau c'est un moyen
je dirais pédagogique et surtout ludique
d'apprendre à nos enfants les valeurs
très simple déjà d'une part notre
patrimoine parce que là vous allez voir
là la thématique sévère sur l'assemblée
nationale mais surtout c'est de mettre
en avant très simplement la la la la
richesse de notre langue l'événement la
dictée pour tous c'est
intergénérationnel c'est de revenir tous
les publics de toutes origines de toutes
horizons de toutes classes sociales et
se retrouver autour notre proto
patrimoine linguistique c'est un gros
problème qu'on voit dans les mails on
voit dans dans les
dans les rapports ou dans n'importe quel
document pas mal de fautes d'orthographe
une action encouragé par des
personnalités de tous les domaines après
gad elmaleh au château de versailles en
2019 c'est l'acteur et réalisateur steve
tran qui a accepté d'être lecteurs sur
cette dictée non je n'ose et c'est notre
futur est il important aujourd'hui de
remettre
remettre tout ça en entre parce que
c'est vrai quand tu vas sur twitter
facebook et sur les réseaux sociaux il
est vrai qu'au niveau grammaire
orthographe ça fait un peu flipper tu
vois moi j'ai peur j'ai des gamins je me
dis moi j'espère que tu vas pas écrire
comme ça je trouve ça très important on
essaie de populariser démocratiser la
dictée et pour la rendre plus jeune plus
cool surtout à travers les nouvelles
générations c'est grâce aux
personnalités l'effort a laissé place au
réconfort en fin de journée avec une
distribution de livres une remise de
prix et de l'eau et une séance de
dédicaces
de retour sur terre après six mois
passés dans la station spatiale
internationale
l'expérience de thomas pesquet auprès
des blocs est terminée mais au collège
debussy le travail continue
l'établissement saint germanois fait
partie des quatre mille cinq cents sites
scolaires sélectionnés par le cn es et
le cnls et nous a reçus cette fois ci
pour un concours un court partant des
sciences de la vie et de la terre les
élèves ont manipulé les blobs avant de
les réveiller mélanie poké s'est rendu
sur place regarder il va falloir
vraiment bien faire tout ce qui est
demandé par de rêve surtout une
expérience digne des grands chercheurs
pour cette classe de 3e du collège
debussy les règles sont donnés par une
biologistes du cnrs audrey du futur dans
le cadre du programme élèves tombent
loeb va découvrir erwin réaction du
globe donc là on a juste mis de l'eau
dans le bloc
avec les bleus son comportement on
observe on
n'a pas forcément pu interagir avec qui
durant toute la nuit c'est intéressant
on a c'était mieux qu'un cours ou ont
fait que parler n'ont été dans dans
l'action ça diffère de ce qu'on fait à
l'école généralement
ça a été assez bien à faire ça a permis
de portions qui veulent faire des études
scientifiques ou quoi de voir ce qu'ils
vont faire plus tard un protocole strict
à suivre pour deux expériences menées
aussi dans l'espace par thomas pesquet
les résultats mené par les différentes
classes participantes sont comparés à
ceux du spationaute français inédit dans
l'année scolaire
habituellement on travaille pas dessus
matin on va pouvoir s'en servir pour une
année 3e c'est l'exploitation d'un
protocole à respecter le protocole
utilisé le matériel en savoir travailler
par binôme en vain en suivant bien tout
protocole son nom des trolls l'aide du
professeur donc ça s'intègre
parfaitement dans le programme une fois
les blobs réveillés ils ont été placés
dans le laboratoire du collège et filmé
le collège debussy continue dans son
approche pluridisciplinaire il nous
donne rendez vous en décembre pour
suivre un cours de français
c'est un rendez vous traditionnel pour
la faculté de droit et de science
politique de l'université versailles
saint quentin la rentrée solennelle
s'est tenue jeudi dernier avec une
saveur peut être un peu particulière
pour cette année celle de 2020 n'avait
pas pu avoir lieu en raison de la crise
sanitaire un reportage avec mélanie poké
célébrer l'excellence ces étudiants
droit son agent de leur promotion chaque
année la faculté les eaux nord lors de
sa rentrée solennelle pour
montrer également les missions de
l'université et d'une faculté de droit
en particulier et puis
fédérer notre communauté autour de
valeurs communes qui sont celles de
l'université avec sa spécificité qui et
l'adossement des formations à la
recherche
une quinzième rentrée de la faculté à la
saveur particulière
l'année scolaire 2020 2021 a été marquée
par des courants distant ciel avec tout
ce travail
je me rends compte que mes efforts sont
récompensés
et ça me fait vraiment plaisir du coup
d'avoir
un prix par rapport à sa malice on s'est
très bien passé de très bons en signant
un très bon enseignement une très bonne
ambiance à lui vécu beaucoup d'entre
aide entre les étudiants et avec cette
pandémie on s'est très bien passé très
bien organisés entre nous présent dans
l'assemblée proches mais aussi
enseignants chercheurs équipes
administratives et partenaires du monde
juridique privée et institutionnelle
cette rentrée était parrainée par les
bâtonniers des barreaux de paris et de
versailles pour concevoir ses activités
du droit une
situation de perspective pour vous
connaissez pas nécessairement bien je
vais essayer de leur transmettre cet
intérêt pour le droit l'importance du
droit dans la société la question de la
de la place de des relations de
l'apaiser le droit n'est pas que du
conflit n'est pas que de la justice le
droit c'est aussi des contrats c'est
aussi la manière de traiter des affaires
c'est aussi la meilleure de régler les
problèmes de la médiation liberté
d'expression et réalités du métier ont
été les principaux sujets évoqués 56
étudiants ont été récompensés
3600 c'est le nombre d'élèves de
l'académie de versailles qui vont
pouvoir participer au service national
universel en 2022 avec de nombreux
retours positifs le sc nuque continue
son déploiement il s'adresse aux jeunes
âgés de 15 à 17 ans qui souhaitent
s'investir dans la vie citoyenne les
inscriptions sont déjà ouvertes sur
scène du point gouv.fr trois sessions
sont déjà prévues en février en juin et
en juillet 2022
et c'est un tout autre sujet à présent
depuis plusieurs mois la vente du
domaine de grignon fait polémique dans
les yvelines
situé sur la commune de thiverval
grignon le site est actuellement occupé
par agro paristech et l'école
d'agronomie déménageant ses activités
sur le plateau de saclay pour septembre
2022 une vente au groupe altarea cogedim
avait été annoncée par l'état c'était au
mois d'août un projet abandonné suite à
de nombreuses mobilisations
une nouvelle procédure de cession sera
donc lancée au second semestre 2022
gérard larcher président du sénat et
elle invite et ce jeudi de l'émission
face aux territoires diffusé notamment
sur notre antenne il était interrogé par
wilfrid errishi sur la gestion du
dossier par l'état j'ai sur ce dossier
illustre la méthode verticale on décide
d'en haut sans lien avec mes élus du
territoire s'en vient d'abord avec le
maire de la commune sans lien avec
l'intercommunalité qui l a proposé de
s'engager dans la reprise de ce domaine
est pourri y construire ensemble coup
construire partagées avec l'état eh bien
non à bercy on a préféré en quelque
sorte de l'argent sonnant et trébuchant
au travers de la vente directe d'un gros
fort heureusement la décision et la
sagesse sont revenus après la
mobilisation de tous les élus des
étudiants les chercheurs et ceux qui
avaient été formés dans cette école
côté culture les archives
départementales des yvelines accueille
depuis ce lundi 22 novembre et jusqu'au
22 avril une exposition consacrée à huit
procès historique elle s'intitule filmer
les pros c'est un enjeu social de
nuremberg au génocide des tutsi au
rwanda le but de cette exposition mettre
en lumière l'importance des caméras dans
les salles d'audience les spectateurs
pourront se plonger dans les extraits
inédits issus de deux mille six cents
heures de films comme par exemple le
procès de klaus barbie premier procès
tenu en france pour crimes contre
l'humanité ou encore les extraits des
procès de paul touvier et maurice papon
collaborationniste du régime de vichy
durant la seconde guerre mondiale et
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver michael elle medoro pour votre
magazine sportif accompagné de bixente
mais rien senti steban pour vos
résultats du week-end très bonne soirée
à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]